you know candace owens got denied a
covet test
okay break this down so basically she
goes
her team emails this uh like kova
testing center in aspen and says hey we
want a covet test for candace owens blah
blah blah she's got to go to this like
thing and they have to have a negative
test to go and they write back and say
sorry we're going to actually turn down
your request for a covet test and i
actually have the full email here
basically they say that at this time
like oh here we go
i just learned this testing request and
the owner of this business i'm going to
refuse this booking and deny service we
cannot support anyone who has
proactively worked to make this pandemic
worse by spreading misinformation
politicizing and discouraging the
wearing of mass and actively dissuading
people from receiving life-saving
vaccinations the only local testing
option is the free the only other local
texting option is a free kiosk by city
hall they mail in their tests to texas
and have inconsistent result times do
not take any appointments so it's walk
in only midday weekdays in their back
alley my team and myself have worked
overtime to exhaustion unpaid and
underpaid this past year spending our
own capital to ensure that our community
remains protected and it would be unfair
to them and to and to the sacrifices we
have all made this past year to serve
you
so
some people are saying oh they're free
to do that they can refuse service to
anyone they want other people are saying
no you're putting cakes you're putting
the community at risk by yeah not
serving yeah this is no different than
refusing to get the vaccine
if you're if you're the type of person
that's like yo vaccine should be legally
mandatory then this is also legally
mandatory like if they're if she's
getting tested we can fairly assume that
she has some symptoms maybe she wants to
go to an event or something like that
but there is a chance that she might
have some symptoms so she fears like she
actually has it and if she doesn't get
100 confirmation
then she might continue
her normal life interacting with other
people potentially spreading the virus
so if these medical workers actually
care about stopping the spread of the
virus
the first thing that they should be
doing is testing this woman
i don't know if these people take the
hippocratic oath but the hippocratic
oath is do no harm
this is potentially harm it is harmful
and not in okay let's say i understand
you don't like her
but don't worry about her worry about
the father that she might meet that
actually has some pre-existing
conditions and could die of covid and
she actually met up with him because she
didn't know for sure that she didn't
have it
you got blood on your hands though if
she does have covet and she ended up
sharing with people they got blood on
their hands right there you're a
murderer
they murder question
their murder is he wrong for doing it
though yes i'm saying that the right
like
he should have but is he wrong because
if it's a private practice just like the
guy who doesn't want to make the gay
cakes it's like you have the right to
but the gay cakes don't affect the whole
community
and it's not healthy they don't
they don't kill people if like gay
people don't have cake they don't die
you know what i'm saying if if it was
they don't what they need it i mean like
their wedding is not going to be like
fabulous
there's other fabulous bakers out there
i bet yeah i bet there's plenty of
fabulous bakers but he's saying the only
other place you can get tested sucks
it's not reliable hahaha basically good
for you now you go do that yeah this is
a petty bitch-ass [ __ ] yeah it's
a pedigree we're in a pandemic and we
ain't got time for these petty bitch-ass
[ __ ] when it comes to like
people's lives yes and like you supposed
to be in this game because you want to
stop this pandemic or at least you want
to help people out make sure they don't
get this excuse me
make sure they don't get this virus and
eventually die or pass on to someone who
could die that's why you should be in
the game but it looks like you in a game
for capitalism yeah it looks like you in
the game would make some money what made
it more confusing and so that came out
and everyone sort of had their initial
reactions and then it came out further
that the actual testing site received
federal and state funding oh really
oh really yo candice go back over there
and get that [ __ ] test different go
back cause your tax dollars paid for
that [ __ ] now i know you're conservative
you don't want to pay no taxes
go over there and get what you deserve
if you're getting federal funding you
getting paid from the government to do
this [ __ ] yeah then you got to do the
people's bidding you don't get to decide
who can or cannot it's not a nightclub
yeah right this is not avenue this is
not [ __ ] one oak this is a testing
center test whoever the [ __ ] gets in
there yeah and i also and like i get
their position if they don't like
candace owens that's perfectly in their
right like if you believe she's very
reasonable if you think she's a grifter
that's trying to just use right-wing
politics to get money and like i
understand where that medicine is but to
try to like deny someone just because
you feel emotional one it's like gonna
backfire because you were putting all of
this you're basically giving her
ammunition yeah like you know this is
someone that thrives off of controversy
and oppression yes so by giving them
this ammunition it's like you know it's
gonna blow up everywhere and on top of
that it's gonna come back on your
business because she's gonna galvanize
her people yeah wrongly so to like try
to attack whoever and granted i don't
think she galvanized anyone to like you
know go attack these people but still
but she knows we're doing it right she
knows the president we're out here
galvanizing him do you this guy's sorry
but this guy's a [ __ ] idiot she he
should have just let her get tested and
then said she was positive even if she
wasn't and then let her keep testing and
just say it's positive every single time
long hauler
you can keep if you really don't like
the message that she's sharing you
really don't like the fact that she's
communicating this information to the
world you really think it's dangerous
keep that [ __ ] i'll cover it and say
some other [ __ ] but then she's gonna be
like i got covered i feel great yeah
now do you think she feels weird about
being an anti-vaxxer because this is the
blackest she's ever been
that might be a real conflict of
interest for her
and she's really kind of selling out her
you know her roots yeah yeah so i just
feel like she should get the vax to just
you know not be so black
well but her people don't want to get
vacs too yeah
her people meaning the whites
of the blacks are meeting yeah it's all
coming together
that's the thing trump is the great
uniter
trump brings people together bro
he did bring all the communities
together finally
for real
what that's a great point that's a great
point united
hippies black people conservatives
you